the year 2020 brings with it a host of
new TV options from broadcast trailers
at Disney Plus franchises
and the great many of them are set to
scratch your science-fiction itch
whether you're watching traditional TV
or binge watching your hearts out on
your favorite streaming service here are
the sci-fi shows to watch out for in
2020 snowpiercer took a long journey on
its way to a television debut and it was
almost as wild and dramatic behind the
scenes as the story being told on the
show the series is based on the 2013
film of the same name
directed by Academy Award winner bong
joon-ho and starring Chris Evans and
Tilda Swinton which was itself adapted
from the French graphic novel that
debuted in 1982 the TV development saga
meanwhile dates all the way back to 2015
in that time since the series has seen
its original showrunner exit its
original pilot director refused to come
back for reshoots and Titus network
changed from TNT to TBS and then back to
TNT it's been a long ride but now
snowpiercer is finally ready to depart
on its television voyage the snowpiercer
series is like the film and graphic
novel set several years after the world
has been enveloped in ice and rendered
uninhabitable the viewers will follow
the residents of a massive locomotive as
it circles a snowbound world with the
focus on the various class struggles and
schemed with in the crude society has
sprung up among the remnants of humanity
starring Hamilton's tuvi Diggs and Oscar
winner Jennifer Connelly Stowe PS sir
will finally debut on TNT on May 31st
2020 for the last eight years Dark Horse
Comics has been home to Pizza Hogan and
Steve Park House says resident alien the
comic book series centers on an alien
from outer space who's forced to hide
out in a small town while he waits for
someone from his species to come and
pick him up since 2018 sci-fi has been
developing a TV series based on the
comics and in 2020 we'll finally get to
see the fruits of that labor resident
alien stars alan tudyk as a title alien
who adopts a human name Harry van der
spiegel after finding himself stranded
on earth Harry decides to take on a
human disguise and pose as a doctor in a
small Colorado town that's so
complicated enough but life gets a
little harder for Harry when he's roped
into a series of mysteries he must help
to solve
oh and there's one kid in the town who
can see right through
human disguise rather than tylium will
premiere on sci-fi in the summer of 2020
the vast collection of shows and
characters known to fans as the era
verse just keeps expanding over at the
CW 2020 Caesar flagship series had
launched a small screen universe arrow
and then it's run after the death of
Oliver Queen in the crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover but that just means
there's more room in the schedule for
future series thankfully for fans who
have been eager to see more of them some
of that room is going to be taken up by
the era versus all-new Superman and Lois
Lane the most prevalent version of
Superman in this universe played by
Tyler hoechlin first popped up on
Supergirl
while his version of Lois Lane played by
Elizabeth tolik debuted in the house
world crossover events in December of
2018
in October of 2019 the CW announced that
it was developing a spin-off series that
would Center on hoechlin Superman and
Telex Lois fulfilling a long-standing
fan wish for a new TV series about the
couple of Steel Superman and Lois does
not yet have a premiere date but will
likely see it arriving sometime in the
fall of 2020 Steve Carell became a
global superstar thanks to his starring
role in the office a workplace comedy
series that led to numerous
opportunities as a film actor in both
comedy and drama in 2020 Carell is
returning to the workplace and he's
bringing office writer Craig Daniels
along for the ride
space force co-created by Carolyn
Daniels will follow a group of
government employees as they tried to
develop the sixth branch of the United
States Armed Forces Kara will play a
general trying to lead the space force
and his mission to get back to the moon
by 2024 Carell is joined on the mission
by an incredible ensemble cast including
the Americans Noah Emmerich Sonic the
Hedgehog's Ben Schwartz and John
Malkovich another actor who's brilliant
at both comedy and drama with Carell
starring as well as co-creating the
series we can expect plenty of office
level gags along the way when space
force hits Netflix in 2020 in the spring
of 2019 Avengers ends game ended a
decade-long era of storytelling in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with a
climactic battle for the fate of all
existence it also set the stage for the
next phase of stories in the MCU we're
only just beginning to see what comes
next but we do know a lot of it will
unfold in the Disney Plus streaming
service through shows like the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier
and event game Steve Rogers past Captain
America shield on to his friend Sam
Wilson better known as Falcon with the
blessing of Steve's best friend Bucky
Barnes aka the Winter Soldier the
upcoming Disney's series we'll explore
the aftermath of that decision as some
content with the legacies now all parts
off with a little help from Bucky this
series will also feature the return of
helmets emo from Captain America Civil
War and Sharon Carter to the MCU as well
as a live-action debut have Captain
America knockoff u.s. agent the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier will arrive on
d-plus sometime in late 2020 the events
of Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame also had a major impact on the
lives of vision and Scarlet Witch the
battle with Thanos left vision
apparently dead and his lover mourning
him but the Paris set to be reunited in
one division a new Disney Plus series
that will somehow trap the two heroes in
a condensed history of television
sitcoms exactly how and why that happens
is the mystery that we're left with
after the teaser but we do know that a
few familiar faces will be back in
action for the show - Yonah Paris has
joined the series as an adult version of
Monica Rambeau the longtime comic book
hero who first appeared as a child in
Captain Marvel the series will also
reintroduced saw supporting character
Darcy Lewis played by kat dennings - the
MCU when it hits dusty + sometime in
2020 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bowel so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]